this builds off of the initial Trilogy
um is there any chance that I know Bruce
is an executive producer is there any
chance that Ash lives in this universe
is there like a familial relation or is
your character like taking up that
mantle well we see you in potential
sequels yeah I mean the scripted Lee
Cronin wrote it it is based off of the
mythology but it's moving forward it's
um it's yeah it's laced with moments
that I feel like and one line is and it
has that like campiness and grit to it
mommy's with the maggots now but then
also
um I don't know it's it's dynamic in a
different way now yeah yeah it's of the
universe there's so many Easter eggs for
fans and plays by the rules yeah I was
going to talk about that there because
there's the scene that you have in the
elevator with the electrical yeah it's
very reminiscent of like the vines yeah
earlier ones
and I have Vines tattooed all over me oh
nice yeah that was are there any other
other I like them that's a great idea a
little self high five
um is there any other Easter eggs that
you guys that worked into the film that
that were of personal favorites oh yeah
yeah I love the Henry of the Easter egg
there's a Henrietta Easter egg in there
that I thought was really smart yeah
yeah totally I mean yeah and then one
line is you know holding the chainsaw
and then the broomstick and also being
able to say come get some yeah felt
pretty good those are pretty good if
they call you in a couple years and
they're like we're gonna do this again
and maybe your character replaces a hand
with a chainsaw yeah would you be in
yeah I'm into being a less grappy hero I
spent a lot of time in this film with my
elbows and knees and covered in bruises
and like not very good with my weapons
so I'm like give me yeah make it like a
part of my body in a limb I'm like that
sounds great yeah did you guys talk to
Jane about her your Evil Dead sister
yeah we have we have yeah but it was
after it was like no one would give you
the heads up of what it takes to go
through an evil dead and they probably
shouldn't actually they actually I think
it's best if you take it just day by day
and you just yeah the only way through
is through and it lets you know the
better yeah yeah but we traded War
Stories oh yeah like similar notes after
that yeah and then like ear infections
and just like yeah the blood being so
sticky where you'd have to walk around
with like a spray bottle to like release
your arms or your neck to like look up
or your eyelids it was yeah it was a
form of torture but the blood of the
film is like a character really we read
uh 1720 gallons of fake blood that
sounds about right I bathed in it yes
yes great facials every day
did you really get an ear infection from
it yeah I mean like well it was
everywhere yeah yeah I had like you it's
it's yeah it's everywhere you're in it
and you're going under and you're
spending five hours in which you know
it's all practical effects which is the
beauty of Evil Dead it's like the
elevator they built it where I was
dipping into the tank it's like we had
like one shot when it like you know the
reference to The Shining yeah but we're
inside it which is intense
um but yeah the Practical element of
Evil Dead it's so rewarding in the
collaboration of all the different
artists involved how hard was it to get
it off at the end of the day yeah I I I
would just disappear and run and go
straight to the shower and it yeah it
was scrubbing yourself raw yeah they
built showers on set yeah any
meaning
you
were either of you guys fans of the
series before you got these jobs
yeah I grew up on Hara mom took me far
too young would always just pull down my
beanies she didn't have to get a
babysitter
um but yeah massive fan of the franchise
in my teens did you have a favorite yeah
I mean I love like evil dead too and
then just like how Army of Darkness just
comes in their bowls so you're jumping
into the franchise you're like what way
are we going where are we gonna land
what was it like when you got to work
realize that you were going to work with
Sam raymie and Bruce Campbell on this I
mean Super exciting and Lee Cronin moves
the script forward in a really beautiful
way but like laces it with like iconic
moments and I mean getting handed a
chain so it was pretty electrifying I
mean you can't do you can't do Evil Dead
without the chainsaw what was it like
wielding the the chainsaw I mean I was
doing my bicep curls regularly each
morning and then I mean lifting it above
my head and revving it it was I mean
from like the tips of my toes to my head
it was just it was electrifying
satisfying
really right yeah yeah when you put it
in I mean I know it's a prop chainsaw
I'm sure they're not gonna yeah this is
real no it's real I'm lifting up they
didn't take the chain off of me okay
come on yeah I don't want to embarrass
you but you've oh you've done Ralph
Lauren campus Chanel Vogue like you've
done you've got a very like this is very
high Glam stuff yeah what was it like
trading all of that in for just like
gallons and gallons of blood so good so
good I I yeah I've got a lot to be
grateful for from being a model and
being in fashion but at the same time it
was not my favorite thing I much prefer
acting I like getting dirty I like a
good Hard Day's Work I think my beer
tastes colder at the end of the day if
I've worked really hard and been in the
mark and like yeah put a good few hours
in
um it was so much fun and to have a role
like this where I get to play a really
bad female is so cool it doesn't happen
very often and I think we haven't seen
the likes of Ellie on screen before this
is a new one and I'm really thrilled for
people to see it you don't look so good
mom
nothing a big old kiss from you won't
fix
I can't think of a lot of other projects
that we've seen where the mother is
going after the children yeah that's
like a very like for us that feels like
I've got kids
you're absolutely and the dad could go
off these families yes I'm not gonna
hurt you I'm just gonna bash your brains
so you know it's taken us some time but
I think
um one of the things I love about
Horrors I think it's breaks new ground
and and it's a good way for us to talk
about society and and what's going on
um and I love that we're we're doing
that we like to think it's just cutting
out like toxic relationships and like
relationships that aren't healthy for
you anymore yeah film explores pick your
family yeah exactly yeah and talk to me
about finding the physicality of this
like getting into the the effects work
the whether it's practical or special
yeah and then like getting the the
Prosthetics and what was that process
yeah it was really wonderful as an
actress like you just it's such a gift
to have something like that because it's
really a full character and I get to
have like two roles in the film and one
of them isn't really human it's sort of
more creature which was so much fun to
work on and I spent a lot of time
creating a movement for her and spent
time with the stunt team not just
working on the stunt choreography but
also the movement of the Dead Eye
um yeah it was a real challenge
um but again so much fun did you look at
anything for inspiration to find that
movement what did you what did you look
at yeah I watched um The Mask Jim Carrey
and The Mask had it a little
sort of hilarity and joy and like a
celebration of just Carnage yeah yeah I
love that I love that that was the
inspiration for that like I can watch
people get chainsawed all day but she's
greater I was like yeah oh God yeah oh
God yeah that's that's a horrifying
that's all truly horrible yeah and now
it's like you're not safe in your
kitchen right like you're starting to
look around your home and like what else
can harm me yeah you guys ever had like
a visceral reaction to a horror film
that you've watched oh yes oh yeah what
was it it the original it I watched that
one it was about 11. I didn't watch a
horror film after that yeah probably The
Grudge you know that sounds yes I would
just hear it all yeah
the Candyman every night when I wash my
face and I pull my head back up from the
sink I'm like convinced there's going to
be a man behind me in the mirror was
there another thing that you guys did
where it was like oh this is absurd it's
gonna look horrifying on screen yeah it
goes all the time every day we shot in
chronological order so it just the heat
got turned up and each day you'd look at
your sides and be like yeah all right it
was like being in a video game you're
like obstacle is this these are your
weapons you're in this room and there's
it was so every day there was so many
challenges but also yeah such fun was
there a moment when you're like
harnessed up either like in the bathroom
scene or in the elevator we were
thinking thinking to yourself like what
what am I doing here what have I signed
up for no that stuff is fun that's the
fun stuff yeah yeah I love being in a
harness and being thrown about it yeah
that was fun it was more actually just
when you went to your trailer and you
were alone that you were like out of
context and they're just looking at
yourself and you're like this is weird
where's on set in context you're like
this is like a playground where it's buy
yourself alone just being like
yeah what am I doing for a living what
does this say about me yeah next time
just go out to Starbucks like that
totally yeah she did you did I did go I
did leave the premises yes
yeah I broke the rules and my hand after
my card gets stabbed I just had blood
all over my hands like this giant
sleeping bag jacket and just like a hood
up to like hide the characters and all
and you know I don't know they didn't
want it to be exposed and it's just like
hood and creepy hand buying something
from like the little local like store
and was just like I realized my hair to
this guy I was just like I just took the
thing left thank you guys so much for
coming in here thank you yeah thank you
congratulations on this really really
good thank you
foreign